what's more dangerous being obese or
being a bodybuilder and i'm like if you
take bodybuilding to the extreme or
obesity to the extreme they're equal
[Music]
hey everyone i'm abby sharp welcome to
my new series fed up every episode i
will be sitting down with a fellow
influencer or content creator to ask
some super tough questions and have real
uncensored unscripted discussions
without the shame and judgment because i
say we are all a little fed up everybody
betrayed me i fed up with this world so
today i'm gonna be tackling one of the
most unexpected collabs of all time
i'm gonna be talking to one of youtube's
most popular fitness creators greg
ducette now before we dive in i want to
remind you to check out my disclaimer
including a trigger warning to those
with past or previous experiences with
disordered eating i also want to remind
you guys all to subscribe to this
channel and ring that bell so that you
never miss out on an episode do it now
before you forget hey greg thank you so
much for joining me today i'm really
excited to chat with you absolutely i'm
looking forward to this been looking
forward to it for a week yes
now
first and foremost um this might be the
most unexpected video collaboration of
all time and i feel like we need to
clear the air a bit
so for those who might not know what i'm
referring to
can you elaborate on what our previous
interactions were like
well absolutely so first of all abby
watched one of my videos or a few videos
and made a video compilation of what i
was eating and at the time i was dieting
for a bodybuilding contest and i was
like shredded and hardly eating starving
myself so she put together a video of
what
greg eats like and i watched a video and
i was like that doesn't really represent
what i eat like and it kind of made it
look like i promote starving and that
i'm like a horrible person for promoting
like starvation diets and you've got to
be shredded and five percent and so it
kind of gave the audience a feeling of
like this guy is a jerk like we don't
want to follow this guy but i was happy
to see so many people are writing in the
comments you know i had a lot of videos
out and they're like actually if you
watch more of his videos it's not really
what he's like overall but like
to your defense anyone that first starts
watching me is like who the heck is this
guy why is he screaming so much and what
is he doing but after like five or ten
videos they kind of get used to it so
that's kind of what happened so i made a
trilogy of videos back and forth it
looked like a netflix documentary kind
of like the shark attack oh my god it's
just client and so all these people did
videos so we went back and forth quite a
bit and so it's been a year i've watched
so many more of your videos and you
actually think a lot more like me than i
ever thought i'm like wait a minute we
actually kind of agree on a lot of this
stuff so that was interesting to see so
it's been a year and now i'm on your
channel being interviewed so
shocking but here i am yeah i think i
mean like you said like we've both grown
so much and i definitely have come to
appreciate that we kind of say a lot of
the same things we just say them
differently and to recap for those who
don't know how do you describe yourself
as a content creator because i mean
there may be a lot of people who are
watching right now who've never watched
your channel before i think most people
get the wrong impression at first they
think i'm some kind of bodybuilder
that's just going to like scream at you
and try to get you shredded and to get
you jacked but really i'm more of a
weight loss channel that i promote
having balance and getting to a healthy
weight and not being unrealistic and i
give a lot of tips on how to lose weight
how to train in the gym and how to have
a diet that you can sustain for the rest
of your life totally and
do you think that the internet like
youtube likes to pit wellness content
creators against each other for
like the spectacle of it all and i don't
know like do we feed into that what do
you think absolutely i did several
videos in regards to your video i could
have given the exact same information
that i gave in those videos but without
your name in the title and without the
kind of back and forth going on and it
would have got half the views because
people want to see one person go against
the other and so when you made that
video it literally helped me because it
gave me such great content to talk about
so anything that you said about my diet
i could say wait wait no no this is what
i actually think or or you're right here
but here you miss that so it gives you
the opportunity to explain yourself by
using someone else's name you get double
the views as if you just kind of
presented the information because people
don't want to go to school again they're
bored of school they want a little bit
more drama a little bit more excitement
not boring and you notice when i speak
in interviews i'm not like
quiet when i do these uh these uh
youtube videos i'm kind of amped up a
little bit more excited i think people
like that they want to enjoy they want
to be entertained
yeah absolutely i mean i i'd like to
think about my content as
infotainment so obviously i'm coming at
all of my my my videos with science um
i'm big on science i'm big on the
research and evidence but of course like
you got to get in there with the click
bait you got to make it dramatic you've
got to make it somewhat sensationalized
or else people are just not going to
watch and so that's always been my
approach i think that there is so much
misinformation out there on the internet
so i need to be equally as enticing as a
content creator but of course when you
get to the video i'm still there kind of
driving down the fact so yeah do you
feel like you're doing kind of like the
same you got the same approach yeah i
like to call out the bs i like to call
out the what's what's lies i call it
more spews for more views people get
away with that all the time it seems
like it's not the smartest people who
are the most popular on youtube it's
usually
it's usually the best looking people
with the best body so maybe that's what
we have maybe we're a little bit of the
attract people but i mean you really
need to have a personality to make up
for like not being drop dead good
looking like i used to say on the
richter scale you have to be like a 9.9
attractive and if you are you can say
anything v shred look at my abs buy my
things and and you can make millions of
dollars but for the normal person it's
like how are you going to stand out you
have to have some kind of personality
but still provide scientific information
because you can give all the science the
information you want with your phds but
if you say it in a boring manner no
one's tuning in yeah totally now
obviously i take a more kind like
intuitive eating approach to diet and
food but i'm really curious
are you completely against intuitive
eating for everyone or like do you think
that there are any merits involved and
like would intuitive eating as you
understand it ever be a goal for you
i think overall intuitive eating is
great for people who have amazing
genetics so they're just the people that
they're already at a healthy weight they
pretty much can eat what they want it
works for them so why shouldn't they
intuitively but for other people who are
struggling with their weight and it's
not easy for them they need to be that
much more careful with what they're
eating kind of like in school if you're
a genius
you don't really need to study that much
it's going to work but if you have
special needs you really need to know
how exactly do you learn are you a
visual learner um do you need hands-on
approach so with dieting this heat the
same thing the worse your genetics are
the more you need to rely on some kind
of a plan to get through it if you do a
lot of cardio you can get away with a
lot more like i'm racing bicycles so i
can eat a lot of calories so i don't
need to count every calorie every macro
like some people do so for me
i'm somewhere in the middle i mindfully
eat um i don't see me as ever just
saying like i'm just eating and i just
whatever i'll always want to have
somewhat of a
i would say i want to maintain an above
average physique not a perfect physique
but something that i'm proud of and so i
think i'll always i'm 45 i think on i
don't know who knows in 40 years
hopefully i make it that long but i
would say i'm always going to be a
mindful eater yeah and i mean i think
that
intuitive eating is not for everyone and
i say that in all of my videos on
intuitive eating because intuitive
eating is not a weight loss diet so if
you are going into intuitive eating and
i get messages about this every single
day oh can i lose weight doing intuitive
eating i say
you might lose weight you might stay the
same weight you might gain weight it
really depends on the person and where
their body wants to be
and also their starting point in their
relationship with food it's so much more
complex than that so i think that like i
said it's just it's not for everyone but
i think that we can pick up certain of
these some of these principles and
tenants and apply them to our eating um
things like like basic things like move
your body in a way that feels good to it
and respect your body and things like
that i think that those are universal
principles that we can all kind of
benefit from but i don't think that
intuitive eating in its entirety as a
movement or an approach to eating is for
everybody to to kind of yeah i really i
really feel like intuitive eating if
you're already overweight and you're not
really active it's very unlikely that
it's gonna solve your problems but if
you're someone who's very active you're
exercising your training or you're an
athlete so to speak that it's probably
gonna work for you like it really comes
down to how active do you are you and
are you in fact overweight and is weight
loss your main concern if it is
probably not the best strategy for you
yeah and the same goes for underweight
too i mean people who are chronically
like if that you have an active eating
disorder i say to people all the time no
you cannot just jump into intuitive
eating because you probably have blunted
your hunger cues so severely that you
can't trust those hunger cues because
people who don't eat enough
they have reduced their metabolism down
to a like a snail's pace so for them to
listen to their body to tell them that
it's time to eat they may not get that
cue and so that's how people kind of get
into this reinforcement that oh well i'm
not hungry i'm listening to my body so i
must be eating enough well when you're
eating 800 calories that is not enough
so we kind of need to for a lot of
people who are just getting started
feeling that relationship with their
hunger and fullness they need to have
what we call mechanical eating which is
like a cast where it's basically a meal
plan for them to eat regularly every few
hours so that they can start to
like start to rebuild those hunger cues
before they just like jump right in to
intuitive eating so
yeah i think that yeah people i've
worked with who are who are clearly
underweight like you know 70 80 90
pounds and whatnot bmi's below 15. it's
very difficult to convince them to eat
more so if i just said just eat
intuitively just kind of like they'll
eat even less than they're eating they
need to have almost like a a calorie
minimum i'm like no matter what you do
you need to eat this minimum goal
somehow because i can't have you
continue to lose weight because it's
already dangerous at this point so i
find it very challenging to work with
people that are really severely
underweight it's it's a completely
different i would say 95 of the people i
work with are people that want to lose
weight so when it's somebody that needs
to gain it's like the opposite uh
training that i need to give them
yeah absolutely and and you're right
they they absolutely do need to have
a structure and and some basically a a
meal plan a minimum in place to to
encourage them to get those calories in
so that they can get those hunger cues
back and it is a bit of a long process
for some people so yeah and it's very
difficult to get them to try different
foods like they don't want to eat
anything that they're not used to that
they haven't tried that's not like
people are talking about well should
labels have calories at restaurants no
they shouldn't because that messes and
i'm like the people that i'm coaching
who are underweight will not eat
something at a restaurant without the
calories listed they just don't dare so
having those calories at least it gives
them the knowledge for them to make that
educated decision so for me i'm a
hundred percent in favor of every
restaurant should have the calories
listed to all the food and some people
are like no as soon as you put calories
it it's gonna trigger people to not eat
because they'll know the calories i'm
like yeah but you should make that
choice like i should know if there's
alcohol what percent in the alcohol i'm
drinking so i don't get too drunk and
drive home it's like it should be there
as information to help us
yeah you know i don't disagree i think
that knowledge is power and having
information more information is better
than less information um but i'm curious
you mentioned working with people who
are severely underweight 15 be it like a
bmi of 15 16 etc
do you feel with your education equipped
to deal with the psycho psychological
element
of some of these situations honestly i
find it's more about the psychological
aspect than the actual coaching they
just want to have somebody to talk to
that they can relate to that they feel
comfortable with a lot of times they
have um several different counselors
doctors working with them and it's not
working and it's like i'm the last
resort somebody that they can trust that
they feel that they can open up to and
so
i mean yeah i mean i have my master's in
kinesiology and i have counseling type
courses that i've taken and you know so
i do have some basic training not as
much as i'd like but certainly better
than nothing so i do feel that i'm able
to help not as much as i want to but
it's better nothing and i mean they have
access to trust me people that are
hiring me for coaching they have access
to whatever they need so i'm just an
icing on the cake so to speak let's take
it back to kind of language because a
lot of my framing and language around
food is about helping people develop
better emotional relationships to eating
especially like we were talking about
with disordered eating patterns so i'm
curious do you think that extreme
calorie and macro counting
ever leads to these patterns and
disordered eating i find it's definitely
a question of like what came first the
chicken or the egg and anything done to
the extreme always is going to possess
some form of a problem or potential to
be a problem i find that happens all the
time but the people that are um that
develop the eating disorders and whatnot
there's almost always something in their
personality that is coming out where
they're they're obsessive compulsive
there's always something else that's
kind of leading to that and so they
might have been for example a normal
eater as a five six seven eight year old
and eventually they start tracking
calories and then they become obsessive
to the point of
how many calories are in that uh
sweetener that i'm putting in my coffee
and it's like is it one or two calories
and i'm like does it matter but they
need to know so you can kind of see a
point where the tracking of calories
becomes way obsessive and i'm like you
can't even track that accurately anyway
it's gonna say zero calories on that
mustard but it's probably three rounded
down so do you really know how many
calories you're taking and when it's
done to that grade of a degree when
46 grams of protein or 48 and i'm like
call it 50. like really like do you care
so that is when it gets to a problem and
i have seen that is that's obviously a
percentage of people maybe it's one
percent of people that start tracking
calories calories are gonna get that
problem later on but i mean there's no
way to end it it's not to say
no one should be tracking calories no
one should be like looking at how much
calories are in food because what if
someday they develop some kind of a
disorder i think you need to educate and
be educated and realize that there are
going to be some problems that arise but
there's not really anything we can do
about it i mean recognize that it might
happen and if it gets to that point like
then let's worry about it yeah no i i
hear you on that so it's interesting
that you only see that in like one
percent so that's very interesting that
that's kind of the case for for the
demographic that's that's coming your
way
yeah i don't see uh crazy large
percentage of people that are tracking
calories and are just being like oh my
god ever since i started tracking
calories i i don't know what to do with
myself anymore it's a very small
percentage of people that are taking
into that great of an extreme that it's
affecting your life in a negative way so
talking about calories what are your
thoughts on cheat days and like do you
do them do you recommend them for your
clients talk to me about cheat days i
have for my entire life been against the
whole cheat day principle and it's
prevalent in contest prep diets for for
bodybuilders bikini competitors or just
generally anyone on a diet it's kind of
like let's eat great all week starve
ourselves and then once a week let's
binge and they post their binges and it
would drive me bonkers it would be 10
000 calories and then they'd write
things like oh i got sick after and i'm
like what percentage of those people are
actually keeping all those calories down
and being a coach having coached so many
people and people confiding so many
people i would say 25 of people who are
having these binge days end up throwing
up after they're not actually keeping
all that food down because imagine
you're on a 1500 calorie diet all week
you just ate 6 000 calories because it's
your cheat day then the guilt sets in
and you're like well i i can't keep this
down so if you restrict so hard all week
and then binge that one day
it's not going to happen and even a
cheat meal any cheat meal to me it's not
a free-for-all like some people are like
i'm gonna eat whatever i want all day
saturday to me that's too long even
whatever i want in one meal that's too
long i can put back 5000 calories with
ease in 30 minutes so if somebody said
hey just eat anything on this diet and
then you know one meal a week you can
eat whatever you want five thousand
calories is what i want two you know two
two liter ice creams easy four liters of
ice cream later then it's like well i i
shouldn't have done that so i'm a
hundred percent a hundred percent
against the cheat meals i do think
people should be allowed to eat off meal
off like whatever they're some people
are eating so restrictive chicken
broccoli and rice i'm like you can't eat
that every day you should be able to eat
at any time during any day on any diet
something that you want in moderation
that way you're not being overly
restrictive and you won't get to the
point where you want to binge cheat and
your will of power it's only going to
last so long so by allowing people to
have that treat
every single day something
they're not going to get to the point
where they need a cheat day yeah no i'm
the exact same way i think it's so easy
to undo the caloric deficit in like one
meal one day whatever when you get into
that cheat day cheat meal mentality like
the first few bites of ice cream is
always gonna taste the best once you get
to behind
once you get to pint two it's just like
oh i'm eating this because it's like the
last supper mentality where you know
that you need to eat it all because
tomorrow the diet starts again but it's
not actually enjoyable anymore
absolutely we've got a lot of diminished
returns so jesse james i don't know if
you know who this guy is popular
youtuber he's always like last bite best
bite no the first bite's the best bite
and as you keep eating the fuller you
get the less you want to eat more so i
always tell people eat till you're full
or satiated but not till you're stuffed
if you start doing that it's just a big
mistake and i hate the concept of like a
cheat meal like like the way you see is
as as a vilifying food that's how i feel
about using the word cheat meal i want
to call it an off meal plan because it's
not a cheat like somebody's like what's
your favorite cheat meal i'm like well
if i say pizza does that mean pizza's
cheating no i eat pizza often so it
doesn't mean usually it's a lower
calorie version of it but even if it's
not it's not a cheat meal it's just me
eating out it's part of my diet i'm
allowed to do that every single day not
all day and not a 16 inch pizza maybe
i'll have four or five slices but not
eight that's the difference between kind
of having balance and just kind of
eating like a cheat meal per se yeah and
i totally agree i think that that's it
you want to incorporate the meals you
enjoy regularly enough that you don't
feel the need to
over indulge in them or overeat them on
that off day or cheat day now as a coach
you probably work with a lot of young
women looking to change their body so
i'm curious over the years do you think
the influence of social media has become
more dangerous for them it's gotten way
worse and it's completely changed when
i'm 45 years old so when i was young it
was about being a rake you have to look
like a javelin you have to be skinny
everywhere it's completely changed now
so that you got to be just as skinny in
the stomach but have curves everywhere
so people are resorting to um
surgeries to get all the the implants
and
uh brazilian butt lifts and that's not
enough you still gotta shrink the waist
down with the uh the apps that you can
control and it's not just still photos
it's literally a video i made a video
once i don't know how to do it but i got
somebody to do it and i was walking
around and i shrunk my way six inches
six inch tiny and so people see that and
they think it's actually them but it's
not you can get rid of all the blemishes
you can change the curves and you're
already sucking in your stomach and
getting the best possible lighting and
doing everything so every image we see
now it's amplified that much i mean 25
years ago
it wasn't as bad the the standards were
different everyone had to be really
skinny but now it's more like impossible
curves that you can't have unless you're
genetically blessed that one in a
million that could have it but that's
the new standard and everyone wants to
have it yeah it's so toxic it's so
dangerous because
obviously we don't all look that way and
we're it's like everyone walking on the
street is now becoming the same person
it's it is alarming to me
um but i'm curious what does healthy
mean to you and do you think larger body
people can be both physically larger and
yet healthy at the same time
well health to me is like first of all
the absence of disease you can't be sick
and next we have three main components
to me there's the mental the physical
and the social and so mentally healthy
being like
loving yourself like i'm proud of myself
you're 300 pound 400 doesn't matter
you're missing an arm you're you have no
legs you you love yourself mentally
you're great and then the social aspect
you have confidence you can talk to
people you're not shy you're not stuck
in your house you have the ability to to
go out with friends and and be happy but
then the physical that's where that's
where it's hard to be
healthy per se at any size because if
you're 600 pounds on that 600 pound life
show
you're not healthy automatically no
matter what we want to tell them like
you're healthy at any you're not you're
not actually healthy you might be
healthy in the other components you
might be you know you love your body
it's great you have friends you go out
that's great but if you're 600 pounds
you can't be healthy you can be
healthier if you do cardio you do
weights you lift and eat and you're
doing all these things and it's healthy
away you can get healthier and i'm all
about being the the healthiest version
of yourself if you're 600 pounds you
probably weren't born to be 200 but you
could probably be halfway it's 400
pounds a lot healthier than 600 so why
not do your best to get halfway to what
would be considered the ideal it's not
about being perfect it's about being the
best that you can be for yourself yeah
and and i i'm a big leader in trying to
you know focus on being what's best for
you as well i think that's a really
important step and that's going to be
that that ideal is going to be different
for different people and unfortunately
we live in a society where we really
only idealize one particular body type
so i agree that if you're 600 pounds
yeah there are going to be obvious
physical
issues going on with your health and
that trying to take on some of these
healthier behaviors that affect one's
weight is probably going to be a really
good thing for you to do
and i can say firsthand firsthand
experience being a bodybuilder
professional bodybuilder having done so
many competitions i'm my least healthy
when i looked my best so i pr if i could
be five percent body fat there's the
ripples i love that but i don't feel
healthy i feel like garbage so that's
why i keep preaching to people don't try
to be like me when i'm doing these
bodybuilding calls it's not easy it's
it's in fact the opposite it's a
nightmare i'm so weak sometimes i'm
laying in the bath i'm like i can't
stand up i don't know how i have to get
driven to the gym sometimes because i
don't trust my ability to drive because
i can't focus i can't concentrate five
percent body fat i would say that's the
closest to death that i've ever been not
only that when i do a bodybuilding
contest i have to dehydrate my body i'm
losing five to ten pounds of water
cutting out water for hours on end using
diuretics abusing pds it is not healthy
if you get my blood work done blood
pressure's not be as good cholesterol is
not in balance but in my off season when
i'm not doing all these things and more
of a healthy weight
the most healthy even the last
bodybuilding show i did which was two
years ago i had to stop bike riding
because i'd get out 30 minutes and i was
like i don't know how i'm making it back
it's so hard because i'm when you're at
five percent below that
there's no energy you don't feel good
it's a nightmare so as much as that 600
pound person is not healthy i think it's
equally not healthy to be on the
opposite extreme the opposite spectrum
so to me it's equal i actually did a
video on that what's more dangerous
being obese or being a bodybuilder and
i'm like if you take bodybuilding to the
extreme or obesity to the extreme
they're equal they are literally
shortening your life so that's why i've
kind of now that i've gotten older i'm
45 i'm just on hrt which is a low dose
testosterone prescribed by a doctor and
i have balance i'm not trying to overly
diet and i'm racing bicycles and i feel
better so somewhere in the middle that's
where you need to be and don't strive to
be perfect just try to be the best that
you can be you get to a certain percent
body fat diet and you start lacking that
energy and not feeling good you gotta
cut it off that's it that's enough just
love yourself enough to accept that you
don't need to be shredded to be a good
person and i'm just curious i'm hearing
you talk about how
horrible it sounds to me
to be at that body fat potential to be
in that competitive mode
what is driving you to do that knowing
that it's not good for your physical
health and it clearly is not good you
don't feel good
what is the motivation there
great question and basically the first
42 shows i did as a bodybuilder were all
natural and so if you're doing it
natural you're not going to take it to
that far of an extreme so my body fat
would have been more of a normal
not that it's normal but more in that
six seven percent range a lot more
doable and it's temporary and why do i
do it because it was the one thing that
i was really good at that i was put on
this earth that i could excel at and the
feeling you get from being successful
and taking on a challenge and overcoming
that and it's not about the plastic
trophy people think it's a oh you just
get a plastic trouble it's no it's
taking on a challenge that i set out to
do and that i achieved it just like
clowning my mount everest is not healthy
doing the tour de france riding your
bicycle for six hours a day that's not
healthy running ultra marathons where
you're running for 14 hours is not
healthy but when you're so good at
something and you're really great at
that you just pursue that i think
everyone in life is kind of like they
want to be good at something whatever
that is and you tend to do it if i was
great at painting i'd be painting all
the time i'm just i'm not i wanted to be
a great triathlete i focus i train so
hard for it i got okay but when i
discovered bodybuilding and i started
doing my first contest and i'm winning i
was like
wow i'm really good at this so you want
to keep being the best version of
yourself so so that kind of answers that
question not everyone can relate unless
you're an athlete or unless you're
really you know trying to be the best in
the world at something it's hard to
understand but that is why it's the
passion you wake up every day with this
goal and you're driven i'm like i'm
gonna do that but i do know it's
temporary i'm not gonna
do that five percent body fat and do it
forever so it's a temporary suffering
maybe i do it once every i haven't done
a show in two years so it's kind of
something that you do every now and then
you push yourself for a little bit and
it's only really that hard the last
month so it's not really you know the
entire time is not bad so you have that
one bad month of wow and then it's over
and you get back to normal okay so
that's super interesting to me i i and
that's what i understood i always
thought of it as like being like
basically like just an athlete you see
that as you know your job and as
something that you're working towards
because of a personal goal and i totally
respect that i mean i know that that's
not something that i would want to
aspire to do but i totally get why
people do and what people get out of
that so thanks for sharing that that's
really interesting but i'm curious
what are you fed up with in the wellness
space what have you had
enough of what frustrates me the most is
the more spews for more views the lies
that people are saying they'll say this
they'll misinterpret science they'll be
like
hey you can get abs in two weeks or you
can eat anything you want as long as
it's not carbs and it's after 12 and
it's like really i can eat as much steak
and butter as i want and lose weight yup
what so that is what drives me bonkers
and that's basically what i made a
career out of i take misinformation that
people are given and i correct it on the
internet and i don't feel guilty about
it i'm like telling you what you need to
hear not what you want to hear you all
want to hear you can eat whatever you
want as long as you don't eat carbs you
go keto you're going to lose all the
weight you want go vegan hey you can eat
whatever you want vegan and you're going
to lose weight
no so that is what i base my channel on
that's what really like grinds my gears
really pisses me off when i see somebody
straight out lying cryotherapy is going
to burn off 500 calories really in three
minutes standing in freezing cold
temperature i'm burning 500 calories buy
me that machine problem is it doesn't
work so i see these people doing that
and you find out they have a company
that they're investing in that has the
crowd and it's like
yeah now i get it you're just trying to
lie to people to make money people don't
have integrity so that is a huge problem
for me yeah a hundred percent and like
you that's also kind of where
what i've made my whole career out of as
well is taking down that misinformation
and there's an endless supply of it so i
think we'll be in we'll have work for a
long long time to come unfortunately
yeah with the invention of tick tock i
mean there's endless content at this
point oh my gosh it's it's so bad tick
tock is really the worst it's the worst
of the worst that's for sure thank you
so much greg this was so much fun um
yes so we're gonna definitely leave all
of your links to your videos and your
channel and your website and your
cookbook i will leave those links below
in the description so thank you again
for coming on i'm sure there will be
some more great collabs in the future so
thank you again
absolutely it was a pleasure
well folks that is all that i have for
you guys today on my new series fed up
thank you so much for watching if
there's someone specific that you would
love to see me interview on this series
definitely leave me a comment below
until then do not forget to give this
video the thumbs up leave me lots of
comments lots of love subscribe to the
channel and i'll see you next time on
abby's kitchen bye